If you look at these cabinet appointees,
they were selected for a reason
and that is the deconstruction of the administrative state.
and if you-
Before he left the Trump administration
former advisor Steve Bannon famously vowed
to deconstruct what he called the administrative state.
A collection of bureaucrats, agencies and unelected rule-making bodies.
Whose decrees govern more and more of our lives.
Cutting regulations and policies that come not directly from Congress,
but from administrators who decide, say,
that the FCC has the ability to regulate the internet
under rules originally created for public utilities.
President Trump's appointee to the Supreme Court, Neil Goresuch
is a critic of the administrative state too.
Questioning the legal validity of rules laid out by bureaucracies
in some of his best known rulings.
And so far many of the President's picks at places such as the FCC,
the FDA, the EPA, and the Department of Education,
seem to be doing just that.
I view it as the leading threat to civil liberties of our era.
I recently sat down with Columbia Law School's Philip Hamburger
to discuss wether the administrative state is a threat to freedom and representative government.
He's one of the leading critics of the administrative state,
and the author, most recently, of:
'The Administrative Threat'